Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Shure:  我给拔了
Shure: I'll unplug it.
Shure:  我再给他插上
Shure: Then I'll plug it back in.
Shure:  OK所以我现在可以去做咖啡了吗
Shure: OK, so can I go make coffee now?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Jake:对你可以去做咖啡了
Jake: Yes, you can go make coffee.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright.
Jake: 去吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Shure:  走
Shure: Let's go.
Choiszt: 现在他们就开始猜了
Choiszt: Now they're starting to guess.
Shure:  去做咖啡
Shure: Go make coffee.
Choiszt:  现在是完全就多亏了你
Choiszt: It's totally thanks to you now.
Choiszt:  我操我他妈好渴
Choiszt: Damn, I'm so freaking thirsty.
Choiszt:  哈哈哈我等了两天
Choiszt: Haha, I've been waiting two days.
Choiszt:  我总算完全了
Choiszt: Finally, it's all done.
Choiszt:  我操这之前都是就是只能戴眼镜
Choiszt: Damn, before this, I could only wear glasses.
Choiszt:  然后现在我爬到我怀里来你知道吧
Choiszt: Now, it's crawling into my lap, you know?
Nicous: 他那个有几了
Nicous: How many does he have?
Jake:没有没有他这个散的
Jake: No, no, it's scattered.
Nicous: OK
Jake: 他这个这5000左右
Jake: It's around 5000.
Nicous: 他这个不是说六点来吗
Nicous: Didn't he say he'd come at six?
Jake:九点额别的还有什么的吗
Jake: Nine. Uh, is there anything else?
Nicous: 还有含他 六个人的手机
Nicous: Including him, six people's phones.
Jake:担心手机是吧
Jake: Worried about the phones, right?
Jake:介绍一下
Jake: Introduce it.
Nicous: 隔离居家
Nicous: Quarantine at home.
Jake:隔离居家住呢
Jake: Quarantine at home, huh?
Nicous: 哦
Nicous: Oh.
Katrina: 一二三四五六七
Katrina: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Nicous: 反应做事可被逼了
Nicous: The reaction is really forced.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Choiszt:  就我一个人
Choiszt: It's just me alone.
Choiszt:  我光透光开相机我他妈的我都
Choiszt: I'm turning on the camera, damn it.
Nicous: 呵呵你他么的
Nicous: Haha, damn you.
Nicous: 任务挑战选高难度
Nicous: Choose the high difficulty for the challenge.
Shure:  你们在干嘛
Shure: What are you guys doing?
Jake:选对了我看了一眼
Jake: I glanced at it and got it right.
Shure:  你们在干嘛
Shure: What are you guys doing?
Jake:就这摆弄这些
Jake: Just fiddling with these.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Oh.
Jake:我们有的这里呢
Jake: We have some over here.
Shure: 我做咖啡
Shure: I'm making coffee.
Choiszt: 小兄弟
Choiszt: Buddy.
把Choiszt: 我这个可以拧下来把底下这个拧
Choiszt: Can I unscrew this from the bottom?
Alice:底下也有遥控器
Alice: There's a remote control down here too.
Jake:来按一下
Jake: Press it.
Shure: 一袋正好十五克
Shure: One bag is exactly 15 grams.
Shure:  买的小样
Shure: Bought a sample.
Choiszt: 就把豆搁里面磨是吗
Choiszt: So we grind the beans in here, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  看看能能闻出上面这些风味吗
Shure: Can you smell the flavors from these?
Choiszt: 还有什么 就是你晒干的时候跟这些一块
Choiszt: What else? Do you dry them together with these when you dry them?
Choiszt:  跟这些一块
Choiszt: Together with these.
Choiszt:  那个晒
Choiszt: Dry them.
Shure:  不是就是它本来其实咖啡豆就是一种果嘛
Shure: No, actually, coffee beans are a type of fruit.
Shure:  就是一种豆子
Shure: They're a type of bean.
Shure:  它其实原本就带这些味
Shure: They naturally have these flavors.
Choiszt: 昂然后把热水加里面就行了
Choiszt: Oh, then you just add hot water, and it's done.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  这就是
Shure: This is it.
Choiszt: 这是要隔奶吗
Choiszt: Do we need to filter the milk?
Shure:  所谓的手冲咖啡没有这就是手冲甭管那个手冲咖啡
Shure: This is called hand-brewed coffee, you don't need to filter the milk for hand-brewed coffee.
Jake:各位醒了吗
Jake: Are you all awake?
Katrina:  咱真的跳这么难的吗呵呵
Katrina: Are we really going to dance something this hard? Haha.
Nicous: 你们之前跳过吗
Nicous: Have you guys danced this before?
Katrina:  我有跳过
Katrina: I have danced it.
Katrina:  但是他们有两个没跳过舞的
Katrina: But two of them haven't danced before.
Katrina:  他这动作还挺碎的
Katrina: The moves are pretty intricate.
Shure:  多60
Shure:  第一步叫闷蒸
Shure:  闷蒸30秒
Katrina:  还挺快的嘞
Shure:  可以
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina:  是不是有点难啊
Shure:  啊不是
Shure:  就是把他那里面的一些
Shure:  二氧化碳给蒸弄出来然后以及
Choiszt: 那我喝了不会二氧化碳中毒把
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure:  还有下下一步
Shure:  我一次一次来
Katrina:  真的吗这么厉害
Katrina:  分解教学
Jake:这截确实适合街舞啊
Choiszt:  这是一次性的
Choiszt:  加多少加了20克
Shure:  呃 15克的豆子
Shure:  240克的水
Shure: 240 grams of water.
Choiszt:  240克的水
Choiszt: 240 grams of water.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  我草
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  我刚想说手术刀级别
Shure: I was just about to say it's like a scalpel.
Shure:  结果多了0.3颗
Shure: But it ended up being 0.3 grams more.
Shure:  问题不大
Shure: Not a big deal.
Shure:  然后剩下就等他
Shure: Now we just wait for him.
Choiszt: 就剩仪器了
Choiszt: Just waiting for the equipment.
Shure:  等等他绿吧
Shure: Yeah, wait for him to go green.
Shure:  般都是1:15啊
Shure: It's usually 1:15.
Shure:  1:16吧好像是
Shure: Or maybe it's 1:16.
Shure:  好
Shure: Alright.
Choiszt: 我曹
Choiszt: Damn.
Shure:  这种
Shure: This kind...
Nicous: 能拉花吗
Nicous: Can you do latte art?
Shure:  这不能嗯对
Shure: This can't, um, yeah.
Nicous: 这都没有奶了是不是然后咖啡了
Nicous: There's no milk in this, right? Just coffee?
Choiszt: 听我说他那种的必须是浓缩的才行
Choiszt: Listen, for that kind, it has to be an espresso.
Shure:  他不是不是浓缩的才可以对
Shure: No, no, it doesn't have to be an espresso.
Nicous: 说明什么呢
Choiszt:  他那种里面有纸箔
Shure:  差不多
Choiszt: 用我的不用我送你的
Shure:  你的也很好
Choiszt: 有冰块没
Shure: 没有冰块
Katrina:  我也没学过这舞试一下
Choiszt: 买点冰块
Shure: 很很热的 这
Lucia: 试一下吧
Choiszt: 确实我发现这个上面dog
Tasha: 不敢想象我跳这个
Shure: 这茶叶好香
Tasha: 会有多么的扭曲
Choiszt: 有点酸
Shure:  是的这都是浅红的豆子
Shure:  然后所以就果香会多一些
Shure:  果香花香
Shure:  不像那咖啡店那种
Shure:  直接做美式的Espresso
Shure:  那种都是深红的
Shure: Those are usually dark red.
Shure:  就是它基本只剩苦味了
Shure: Basically, it's just bitter.
Choiszt: 哎美式会用expresso做吗
Choiszt: Hey, does American coffee use espresso?
Shure:  是它就是expresso
Shure: Yes, it's just espresso.
Shure:  加水就叫美
Shure: Add water and it's called Americano.
Nicous: 哎浓缩浓缩是什么意思啊
Nicous: Hey, what does "espresso" mean?
Shure:  浓缩就是咖啡机弄出来的
Shure: Espresso is made by a coffee machine.
Shure:  大概这么一勺子的
Shure: About a spoonful of it.
Shure:  就类似于你喝酒的勺子杯
Shure: It's similar to a shot glass for alcohol.
Shure:  一勺子的液对
Shure: A spoonful of liquid, yes.
Nicous: 咖啡
Nicous: Coffee.
Nicous: 那咖啡液怎么弄咖啡豆磨的
Nicous: How do you make coffee liquid from coffee beans?
Shure:  就是演演示一下
Shure: Let me demonstrate.
Shure:  磨成粉然后放到一个这么样的
Shure: Grind them into powder and put it into a small bowl.
Shure:  一个一个粉碗里
Shure: A bowl for the powder.
Shure:  然后给他压成饼
Shure: Then press it into a puck.
Shure:  然后上到机器上
Shure: Then put it on the machine.
Shure:  然后他开始压出来那么一点浓缩液
Shure: And it starts pressing out a bit of espresso liquid.
Shure:  可以了再晃呵呵呵
Shure: That's it, shake it a bit, haha.
Nicous:  有点太酸不是不像咖味我觉得这个香
Nicous: It's a bit too sour, doesn't really taste like coffee, but I think it smells nice.
Katrina:  你们泡的是哪个呀
Katrina: Which one did you guys brew?
Choiszt: 这就是这就是咖啡啊
Choiszt: This is it, this is coffee.
Katrina:  泡那个云南那个吗
Katrina: Did you brew the Yunnan one?
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Nicous: 是吗
Nicous: Really?
Shure:  来来来尝尝
Shure: Come on, give it a try.
Katrina:  云南那个很酸
Katrina: The Yunnan one is really sour.
Shure:  我自己手冲的
Shure: I brewed it myself.
Shure:  尝一口
Shure: Take a sip.
Katrina:  尝尝
Katrina: I'll try it.
Shure: 给给你上一杯
Shure: Let me get you a cup.
Nicous: 这个好好喝啊让我来
Nicous: This is really good, let me try.
Katrina:  早上那个云南的也很酸
Katrina: The Yunnan one this morning was also very sour.
Shure:  酸
Shure: Sour.
Katrina:  看看怎么手冲
Katrina: Show me how you brew it.
Katrina:  就是你把它倒着
Katrina: Do you pour it like this?
Katrina:  这样倒吗
Katrina: Like this?
Shure:  不是什么叫倒
Shure: No, what do you mean by pour?
Shure:  你在说什么
Shure: What are you talking about?
小黄: 像那个干水
Nicous: Like that dry water.
Katrina:  我以为是你
Katrina: I thought it was you.
Nicous: 我曹给他喝了一口干水
Nicous: Oh man, I gave him a sip of dry water.
Shure:  拿这个就那么那么那么一点点浇上去
Shure: Just use this, and just pour a little bit over it.
Shure:  就这种
Shure: Like this.
Katrina:  哦懂了
Katrina: Oh, I get it.
Katrina:  感觉得灌很多牛奶啊
Katrina: Feels like it needs a lot of milk.
Shure: 这付个
Shure: This is how you do it.
Nicous: 到底是什么味啊
Nicous: What does it really taste like?
Shure:  我哈哈
Shure: I...haha
Choiszt: 那我就开喝了
Choiszt: Then I'll start drinking.
Nicous:  有点太酸了有点不习惯
Nicous: It's a bit too sour, not quite used to it.
Katrina:  像那口服液
Katrina: Feels like an oral liquid.
Nicous: 确实
Nicous: Indeed.
Shure:  然后咖啡豆后天到
Shure: The coffee beans will arrive the day after tomorrow.
Shure:  这个确实有点太酸了
Shure: This is indeed a bit too sour.
Katrina:  牛奶在下面
Katrina: The milk is at the bottom.
Shure:  这位是你的
Shure: This one is yours.
Choiszt:  让我来直播
Choiszt: Let me do the live stream.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Choiszt: 可以吗
Choiszt: Is it okay?
Shure:  可以你可以感觉一下
Shure: Yeah, you can feel it.
Shure:  这个感觉
Shure: This feeling.
Shure:  味道其实差不多
Shure: The taste is actually similar.
Shure:  会比刚才淡一些
Shure: It's a bit lighter than before.
Choiszt: 对没有那个那么酸了
Choiszt: Yeah, it's not as sour as before.
Choiszt: 但咖啡味还是有的
Choiszt: But it still has the coffee flavor.
Shure: 这个把那个滤纸拿哎吆吆他在滴
Shure: Take out the filter paper... oh, it's dripping.
Choiszt: 底下这个可以喝吗
Choiszt: Can we drink what's at the bottom?
Shure:  不可以不是没没有这么喝的
Shure: No, that's not how you drink it.
Shure:  就跟你泡茶
Shure: It's like when you brew tea.
Shure:  倒茶台茶台里的
Shure: You pour out from the tea table.
Lucia: 我们这里有啊
Lucia: We have that here.
Lucia: 那个镜子太小了
Lucia: But the mirror is too small.
Lucia: 微微你醒了吗
Lucia: Tasha, are you awake?
Shure: 真的要吗
Shure: Do you really need it?
Jake:微微不会在缝里偷看我们吧
Jake: Tasha wouldn't be peeking at us through the gap, right?
Choiszt: 应该不脏吧
Choiszt: It shouldn't be dirty, right?
Shure:  哈哈脏倒是应该不脏
Shure: Haha, it shouldn't be dirty.
Choiszt: 这个喝浓缩吗
Choiszt: Do you drink this as an espresso?
Tasha: 你要打开门吗
Tasha: Do you want to open the door?
Shure:  额也不是就跟那个是一样的都是
Shure: Uh, not really, it's the same as...
Choiszt: 这和那个酸味浓度一样
Choiszt: This one has the same sourness level.
Shure:  对主要是豆子酸味重
Shure: Yeah, it's mainly because the beans are quite sour.
Choiszt: 这豆子最多能放260克
Choiszt: These beans can hold up to 260 grams.
Shure:  就是1比16 对
Shure: It's a 1:16 ratio, yeah.
Shure:  就是240克
Shure: So that's 240 grams.
Choiszt: 哎这种配置是就是你自己定的还是额那个咖啡
Choiszt: Hey, is this setup something you decided or is it from the coffee...
Shure:  官方建议
Shure: It's the official recommendation.
Tasha: 哎呀我这眼
Tasha: Oh man, my eyes...
Tasha: 睛是有路的
Tasha: There's a path in my vision.
Choiszt: 这种咖啡都是一比十六是吗
Choiszt: Is this type of coffee always 1:16?
Katrina:  这个动作有点点俗
Katrina: This move is a bit vulgar.
Shure: 大多数都是
Shure: Most of them are.
Lucia: 刚站在这里看还没有看到
Lucia: I didn't see it when I was standing here.
Shure: 完了忘给
Shure: Oh no, I forgot to give...
Choiszt: 你喝了吗巨酸
Choiszt: Did you drink it? It's super sour.
Shure:  后天我的咖啡豆就到了就可以
Shure: My coffee beans will arrive the day after tomorrow, so we can...
Choiszt: 想象中的
Choiszt: As I imagined.
Jake:你们记得跳啊
Jake: Remember to jump, guys.
Nicous: 我们也跳
Nicous: We should jump too.
Katrina:  真的要跳
Katrina: Really need to jump?
Jake:嗯你们也要跳
Jake: Yeah, you guys need to jump too.
Lucia: 我这边反光不好打
Lucia: The reflection here isn't good for lighting.
Lucia: 在打在这个人上看不清楚啊
Lucia: The light on this person isn't clear.
Tasha: 要不要把那个窗帘放下来或者
Tasha: Should we lower the curtain or something?
Katrina:  怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong?
Choiszt: 把那个亮度调亮点
Choiszt: Adjust the brightness a bit.
Lucia: 或者我们现在需要用到这个这个灯吗
Lucia: Or do we need this light right now?
Katrina:  天呐我们像练习室
Katrina: Oh my God, we look like we're in a practice room.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我们前面应该还有一个大镜子
Lucia: We should have a big mirror in front of us.
Lucia: 就更好了
Lucia: That would be even better.
Jake:ok给你们补个光吧
Jake: Okay, let me add some light for you guys.
Lucia: 这样就能
Lucia: That way we can...
Katrina:  你看他还挺快
Katrina: Look, he's pretty quick.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 那个那个那个影楼灯
Lucia: That studio light...
Lucia: 那个柔光板一定要加上哈哈
Lucia: You definitely need to add that soft light board, haha.
Shure: 稍微给开一下这个
Shure: Slightly open this.
Katrina:  这动作感觉好陌生
Katrina: This move feels so unfamiliar.
Tasha: 是所以我在想要跳这个吗
Tasha: Yeah, so I'm wondering if we should dance this?
Tasha: 我怕对他们太难了
Tasha: I'm afraid it might be too hard for them.
Shure:  我们跳昆卡吧
Shure: Let's dance the Kunku.
Katrina:  可以看不知道跟这个哪个男可以看
Katrina: Let's see if this guy can do it.
Katrina:  他跳不好很丑你知道吗
Katrina: If he can't dance well, it'll look really bad, you know?
Katrina:  跳不好就是大猩猩
Katrina: If he can't dance well, it's like a gorilla.
Shure:  昆卡啊卡
Shure: Kunku, yeah.
Katrina:  那这个
Katrina: Then this...
Jake:没多少钱二十块钱
Jake: It's not much, twenty bucks.
Shure:  如果我们看电影什么的
Shure: If we watch a movie or something...
Shure:  是在楼上看是吗
Shure: Do we watch it upstairs?
Jake:看什么电影
Jake: What movie?
Shure:  比如说想要看看个电影什么的
Shure: Like if we want to watch a movie or something.
Katrina:  可以吃火锅
Katrina: We could eat hotpot.
Shure:  集体观影
Shure: Watch together as a group.
Jake:可以 吃火锅就是光看电影没有动作
Jake: Sure, eating hotpot and watching a movie, no problem.
Lucia: 我们可以把它投到这个上面吗
Lucia: Can we project it onto this?
Lucia: 把这个视频
Lucia: This video.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  好像也行
Shure: Seems like it works too.
Lucia: 这样是不是方便学一些
Lucia: Isn't it easier to learn this way?
Lucia: 因为只要这个灯打开
Lucia: Because as long as this light is on,
Lucia: 就是他屏幕上就会有一个亮点
Lucia: there will be a bright spot on his screen.
Lucia: 然后我有点散光
Lucia: And I have a bit of astigmatism.
Jake:可以呀可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 所以我看动作有点看不清楚
Lucia: So I can't see the movements clearly.
Katrina:  哦买噶出道了
Katrina: Oh my god, debut!
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 但有个问题是我们好像只能投5次
Lucia: But the problem is, we can only vote five times.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 是不是应该把这个宝贵的机会
Lucia: Shouldn't we use this valuable opportunity...
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  这小米这个可以
Shure: This Xiaomi one is fine.
Shure:  那什么投的
Shure: What did you use to vote?
Shure:  那个我来解决一下
Shure: Let me handle it.
Jake:可以搞一下
Jake: Yes, handle it.
Jake: 好你来解决一下
Jake: Okay, you handle it.
Katrina:  咱应该是只跳了1分 1分40
Katrina: We should have only jumped for 1 minute 1 minute 40.
Choiszt: 你这正常多少
Choiszt: What's your usual time?
Katrina:  应该只跳到1分30
Katrina: It should be around 1 minute 30.
Katrina:  差不多吧
Katrina: About that.
Katrina:  再再看一遍
Katrina: Let's watch it again.
Shure:  总感觉你好像长高
Shure: Feels like you've gotten taller.
Shure:  了呢这两天
Shure: In the past few days.
Shure:  哦没有
Shure: Oh, no.
Shure: yesok
Shure: Yes, okay.
Shure:  他怎么又变成这个德行了
Shure: Why did he turn into this again?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure:  好像那个送孩子来上跳舞课
Shure: It's like bringing a kid to dance class.
Shure:  然后在后面等着
Shure: And waiting in the back.
Shure:  哈哈哈像吧
Shure: Haha, doesn't it look like that?
Katrina:  我要换双鞋子
Katrina: I need to change shoes.
Katrina:  不行这个
Katrina: These won't do.
Jake:这个
Jake: This one...
Lucia: 等一下我如果戴着眼镜进去
Lucia: Wait, if I wear glasses inside,
Lucia: 是不是就拍到我乱七八糟的箱子
Lucia: will it capture my messy box?
Katrina:  没事我已经拍过很多遍了
Katrina: No worries, I've filmed it many times already.
Choiszt: 我们应该直接学恰舞就可以了
Choiszt: We should just learn the cha-cha dance.
Jake:就是这样的
Jake: Exactly.
Katrina:  差不多学到这
Katrina: That's about it for learning.
Lucia: 差不多我觉得已经很很多
Lucia: Yeah, I think we've learned quite a lot.
Choiszt: 学完了
Choiszt: Finished learning.
Katrina:  没有只学了一分半
Katrina: No, we only learned for a minute and a half.
Katrina:  你看那个
Katrina: Look at that.
Jake:早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Katrina:  要不直接一起跟
Katrina: How about we just follow along together?
Shure:  早上好叶之城
Shure: Good morning, Leaf City.
Shure:  昨天的死人乐透
Shure: Yesterday's deadly lottery.
Katrina:  确定学这个了吗
Katrina: Are you sure you want to learn this?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 你们怎么样觉得
Jake: What do you guys think?
Katrina: 有意义嘛
Katrina: Is it meaningful?
Lucia: 感觉这个有一点点小难
Lucia: I feel like this is a bit difficult.
Lucia: 但是只要大家有决心
Lucia: But as long as everyone is determined.
Lucia: 这肯定就能学会
Lucia: We can definitely learn it.
Shure:  你怎么还PUA我们呢
Shure: Why are you still PUA-ing us?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈其实还有一个
Lucia: Hahaha, actually there's one more thing.
Lucia: 你今天看群里了吗
Lucia: Did you check the group chat today?
Shure:  嗯你给他稍微再低一点头
Shure: Hmm, lower your head a bit for him.
Katrina:  还有一个good time和
Katrina: There's also a good time and...
Choiszt: 哎这个能动不能调
Choiszt: Hey, can this move or be adjusted?
Shure: ok
Shure: Okay.
Jake:开玩笑的
Jake: Just kidding.
Jake: 这个不要动
Jake: Don't touch this.
Jake: 就是这个要叫住你每次动一次叫住
Jake: Every time you move it, you need to call out.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:抓一下最低标准
Jake: Set the minimum standard.
Shure:  好他现在不动了
Shure: Okay, now it's not moving.
Tasha: 这简单
Tasha: This is simple.
Choiszt: 这个简单
Choiszt: This is simple.
Jake:就家里娃从小学变幼儿园了
Jake: The kid at home went from elementary to kindergarten.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Katrina:  这可能会学的比较有成就感
Katrina: This might feel more rewarding to learn.
Jake:昂确实
Jake: Yeah, indeed.
Lucia: 拖鞋都快让我跳的甩出去了
Lucia: My slippers almost flew off while I was jumping.
Lucia: 哈哈换一个跟脚一点
Lucia: Haha, change to a more secure pair.
Katrina:  嘿
Katrina: Hey.
Shure:  操我的
Shure: Damn, mine.
Shure:  我的我的
Shure: Mine, mine.
Shure:  我的b站怎么不堪入目呢
Shure: Why is my Bilibili so unbearable?
Shure:  有点哈哈哈哈
Shure: A bit, hahaha
Choiszt: 用我B站吧
Choiszt: Use my Bilibili account.
Shure:  没没有关系
Shure: No, it's okay.
Shure:  你发我直接点链接进去吧哈哈哈
Shure: Just send me the link directly, haha.
Choiszt: 你搜吧
Choiszt: Just search for it.
Shure:  叫啥呀这个
Shure: What's it called?
Choiszt: 你电脑什么样啊这不还好吗
Choiszt: What kind of computer do you have? Isn't it fine?
Katrina: 偶像万万岁
Katrina: Long live idols!
Choiszt: 就三个对象还好呀
Choiszt: Only three objects, it's fine.
Shure:  对上面
Shure: Right, on top.
Choiszt: 开了快看
Choiszt: It's open, look quickly.
Shure:  教了一些小知识
Shure: Teaching some tips.
Choiszt: 跟不上去总觉得我
Choiszt: Can't keep up, I always feel.
Tasha: 我觉得这个不错
Tasha: I think this one's good.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha: 他这个他的动作重复成功率很高
Tasha: His repeated action success rate is very high.
Shure: 他叫什么他叫什么这个
Shure: What's his name? What's his name?
Tasha: 偶像万万岁
Tasha: Long live idols.
Shure:  偶像
Shure: Idols.
Choiszt: 好玩 我们还在跳那个
Choiszt: Fun, we're still dancing to that.
Katrina:  你要跳那个吗
Katrina: Do you want to dance to that?
Nicous:  对我们要有好的
Nicous: Yeah, we need a good one.
Shure: 这个是吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Katrina:  投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Choiszt: 来个最难的
Choiszt: Let's do the hardest one.
Nicous: 来个
Nicous: Let's do it.
Choiszt: 来个难一些的
Choiszt: Let's do a harder one.
Katrina:  不是这个版本
Katrina: Not this version.
Katrina:  这是原男团版本
Katrina: This is the original boy band version.
Choiszt: 跳那个跳那个成年人那个
Choiszt: Dance to that, dance to the adult version.
Lucia: 什么刚那个是原版吗哈哈
Lucia: Was that the original version? Haha.
Choiszt: 大硕那个
Choiszt: The Dashuo one.
Katrina:  咱是这个
Katrina: We're doing this one.
Choiszt: 这他妈里面只有跳
Choiszt: This one only has dancing.
Shure:  昂
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 嘿
Katrina: Hey.
Choiszt: 这个太简单了这个应该出场
Choiszt: This is too easy, this should be the entry.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Choiszt: 这个明明就是那个学校课间操
Choiszt: This is clearly the school recess exercise.
Shure: 七彩阳光嘛这不
Shure: Isn't this the Rainbow Sunshine?
Choiszt: 左边这个完全没有
Choiszt: The one on the left has none at all.
Shure: 广场舞级别
Shure: This is at the level of plaza dancing.
Shure:  这个我要
Shure: I want this one.
Shure:  queencat的
Shure: The queencat one.
Katrina:  决定一下吧
Katrina: Make a decision.
Katrina:  今天下午讨论一下
Katrina: Let's discuss it this afternoon.
Choiszt: 我曹啥时候转场啊
Choiszt: Damn, when are we switching scenes?
Tasha: 还有分成哈哈哈
Tasha: And there's a split, haha.
Shure: 哎我曹
Shure: Oh damn.
Lucia: 真的很难说短剧和这个谁尬
Lucia: It's really hard to say which is more awkward, the skit or this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Choiszt: 我说实话这个跳的真蛮尬的
Choiszt: To be honest, this dance is really awkward.
Choiszt: 我踏马的高中跳操都么这么认真
Choiszt: I wasn't this serious even in high school exercises.
Shure:  说实话跳这个是态度不行
Shure: Honestly, the attitude is not right for this dance.
Shure:  跳yesok这是能力不行
Shure: Dancing "yesok" is just a lack of skill.
Choiszt: 当时还有跑步
Choiszt: Back then, we even had running.
Nicous: 好累啊
Nicous: So tired.
Choiszt: 我曹下的勒
Choiszt: Damn, this is exhausting.
Shure:  我们先拿这个热身好吧
Shure: Let's use this to warm up first, okay?
Katrina:  好的看来你们还是想学那个
Katrina: Alright, it seems you guys still want to learn that.
Shure:  哎呀操哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Oh damn, hahaha.
Choiszt: 加油新生活加油
Choiszt: Go for it, new life, go for it.
Shure: 要不
Shure: How about...
Lucia: 这个有3分钟
Lucia: This one is 3 minutes.
Lucia: 那个是只跳1分钟
Lucia: That one is only 1 minute.
Lucia: 哦这是桃心
Lucia: Oh, it's a heart shape.
Lucia: sorry又错一次
Lucia: Sorry, wrong again.
Shure:  万万岁
Shure: Long live!
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Choiszt: 还他嘛有啊
Choiszt: There's still more?
Lucia: 课间操没这么短
Lucia: The break exercises aren't this short.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不是
Lucia: Haha, no.
Lucia: 怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 为什么又开始跑步
Lucia: Why are we starting to run again?
Choiszt: 不是他这
Choiszt: Isn't it...
Katrina:  哎有点累哈
Katrina: Oh, a bit tired.
Lucia: 这运动量其实也不小了哈哈呜呜
Lucia: This workout is actually quite substantial, haha, sob sob.
Choiszt: 直接pas这个直接pas这个
Choiszt: Let's just skip this, let's just skip this.
Nicous: 这个太简单了
Nicous: This is too easy.
Choiszt: 太累了
Choiszt: So tiring.
Katrina:  太简单了
Katrina: Too easy.
Nicous: 没有任何挑战性
Nicous: There's no challenge at all.
Choiszt: 这个太累了好吧
Choiszt: This is too tiring, alright.
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 不行
Shure: No way.
Katrina:  那咱跳一盒可以吧
Katrina: How about we skip a box?
Jake: 就学完了是吧
Jake: So, you finished learning it?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Nicous: 这太简单学完了
Nicous: This is too easy, we're done.
Lucia: 他们已经这个全都学会了
Lucia: They've already learned all of this.
Shure:  觉得这个没有难度
Shure: They find it not challenging.
Shure:  我们需要学学有点东西的东西
Shure: We need to learn something with a bit more substance.
Shure:  哎我的b站又烂掉了
Shure: Ugh, my Bilibili crashed again.
Lucia: 或者我们跳worst
Lucia: Or we can dance to "Worst".
Lucia: 这个我
Lucia: This one I...
Lucia: 哈哈复习worst快一点
Lucia: Haha, let's review "Worst" quickly.
Tasha: 是很早很早前的舞了
Tasha: It's a very old dance.
Katrina:  高中的时候就跳
Katrina: We danced it in high school.
Shure:  你还没有开
Shure: You haven't started.
Katrina:  对我那会大一的时候跳
Katrina: Yeah, I danced it in freshman year.
Shure:  你没有
Shure: You haven't...
Tasha: 我开了
Tasha: I did.
Shure: 你先把这退出去一遍然后再进
Shure: Exit and then re-enter the app.
Lucia: 但是得学个新的
Lucia: But we should learn something new.
Jake: 我再看一下
Jake: I'll check again.
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
Katrina:  呃我想想本来备选还有什么来着
Katrina: Uh, let me think, what else do we have in reserve?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春和
Katrina: "Running Youth" and...
Lucia: 奔跑青春
Lucia: "Running Youth".
Lucia: 可以让他们去跳那个solo
Lucia: We can let them dance the solo.
Nicous: 再跳我要解除封印
Nicous: Dance again, I'm going to break the seal.
Jake:啊你要干嘛了
Jake: Ah, what are you going to do?
Nicous: 美事
Nicous: Something great.
Shure:  要脱光膀子了是吧啊
Shure: You're going to take off your shirt, right?
Nicous: 我要好好跳舞了
Nicous: I'm going to dance seriously.
Katrina:  那就跳这个
Katrina: Then let's dance this one.
Katrina:  hiss OK了
Katrina: hiss OK
Shure: 可以
Shure: Got it
Katrina:  哎为什么声音这么小
Katrina: Hey, why is the sound so low?
Jake: OK OK
Jake: 声音声音可以弄大一点
Jake: We can make the sound louder
Katrina:  我已经调到最大了
Katrina: I already set it to the max
Shure: 最大了是吗
Shure: Maxed out, huh?
Nicous: 这是学舞
Nicous: Is this dance practice?
Katrina:  对这是教学
Katrina: Yeah, it's a tutorial
Nicous: 我就不用教学直接跳
Nicous: I don't need a tutorial, I can just dance
Tasha: 真假哈哈哈
Tasha: Really? Hahaha
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Whoa, damn
Jake: 好了嗯好行
Jake: Alright, yeah, good
Shure:  太sexy了吧这个
Shure: This is too sexy
Katrina:  这正常的绝世元素
Katrina: This is just the usual cool stuff
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Jake: 你也跳啊
Jake: You dance too
Jake: 你们跳一跳
Jake: You guys dance a bit
Lucia: 怎么又叫整一次
Lucia: Why are we doing it again?
Jake: 因为刚刚有没有开
Jake: Because it wasn't on earlier
Katrina:  刚开始是背过去的 2345678
Katrina: At the start, you turn your back, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
Lucia: 哦哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see
Choiszt: 太挤了
Choiszt: It's too crowded
Tasha: 哎要不要把这个往后推一推
Tasha: Should we push this back a bit?
Shure: 威武
Shure: Impressive
Katrina:  坏了哈哈
Katrina: Oops, haha
Shure:  哪一步不会了
Shure: Which step did you miss?
Nicous: 太简单了
Nicous: Too easy
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 我曹
Shure: Oh crap
小薇 : 你不是要跳这个
Tasha: Weren't you going to dance this?
Lucia: 你能跟上吗
Lucia: Can you keep up?
Shure: 没都没都没都
Shure: No, no, no
Jake: 你没电了吗看一下
Jake: Are you out of battery? Check it
Jake: 再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again
Jake: 对就说一个 15156
Jake: Yeah, just say 15156
Shure:  行了这
Shure: This is fine
Nicous: 太简单了
Nicous: Too easy
Katrina:  这个
Katrina: This one
Nicous: 太简单了
Nicous: Too easy
Shure:  噢噢噢噢ydsok234567822345678323456784234567 耶
Shure: Oh oh oh oh ydsok234567822345678323456784234567 Yeah
Shure:  洒洒水
Shure: Piece of cake
Shure:  三四五六七八二二三四五六七八
Shure: Three four five six seven eight two two three four five six seven eight
Shure:  三二三四五六七八四
Shure: Three two three four five six seven eight four
Shure:  二三四跑
Shure: Two three four run
Shure:  yes OK
Shure: Yes OK
Shure:  二三四五六七八
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight
Shure:  二二三四五六七八三二三四
Shure: Two two three four five six seven eight three two three four
Shure:  顶二
Shure: Top two
Tasha: 我已经自动有了带教老师
Tasha: I already have a mentor automatically
Shure:  4234
Shure: 4234
Shure:  一二三四
Shure: One two three four
Tasha: 哈哈厉害
Tasha: Haha impressive
Shure:  是不是武士就是都是这个样子
Shure: Aren't all warriors like this?
Nicous: 我觉的咱可以直接快进到一倍速
Nicous: I think we can just speed it up to 1x speed
Katrina:  突然把屁股顶了出去
Katrina: Suddenly stuck my butt out
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  123456
Shure: 123456
Shure:  5678
Shure: 5678
Tasha: 连左右不分
Tasha: Can't even tell left from right
Shure:  12345678
Shure: 12345678